I'm Dan Rawls and here's some advice on
how to be single according to the movies
I'm done so you're single again whether
your girl broke up with you you never
had anyone to begin with or your boy toy
died in the ocean you're gonna need to
follow a few steps to return to normalcy
and avoid becoming a crazy cat lady step
1
cry it out sometimes it takes some good
old-fashioned waterfalls to reset your
system it may be all you need to feel
happy again
but if crying doesn't work try crying
again with ice cream chocolate donut
skittles and diabetes step 2 go in wild
singlehood can be a blessing in disguise
while you're so low you might as well
party like Vince Vaughn dance on tables
like Vince Vaughn give your friend some
motorboating tips like Vince Vaughn and
fight Santa's like Vince Vaughn do what
you want before you know it you'll be
having the time of your life until you
get to step 3 realize you're doomed to
die alone if you don't find someone soon
drinking wine random sex and video games
can't last forever eventually you'll
need to get back on that dating horse
within one hour you'll each have 20
dates don't please don't do this
yes dating can be scary that's why you
need step 4 learn to flirt it doesn't
matter if you're dead a teddy bear or a
d-bag anyone can flirt you can flirt
with your words flirt with a flute flirt
with York or flirt with hot dogs like
Vince Vaughn if at all possible just be
Ryan Gosling things tend to work out for
that guy but most importantly you can at
least cling to your single pride and
tell your ex and that my friends is how
to be Vince Vaughn I mean single I
apologize to you if I don't seem real
here to jump into a force awkward
intimate situation that people like to
call dating
you